les yvelinois en ont désormais
l'habitude pour la septième année
consécutive le département va accueillir
en mars la course cycliste paris nice
l'annoncé officielle a été faite ce
mardi 3 janvier à versailles devant plus
d'une cinquantaine de journalistes dont
je crois que c'est d'abord un plaisir
pour les yvelinois
c'est pas pour nous qu'on fait ça
naturellement j'ai une façon de faire a
parlé des yvelines
c'est valorisant pour notre département
après mon repas en 2015 et conflans
sainte honorine en 2016 c'est la ville
de bois d'arcy qui a été retenue pour
ouvrir le bal sur cette course du soleil
le 5 mars prochain
cette année pas de prologue mais une
étape de 148 kilomètres dans la vallée
de chevreuse il fallait mettre un petit
peu la lumière sur sur la vallée
heureuse y avait quelque chose à faire
c'est la vallée de chevreuse
en sortant de dollars si on pouvait
faire quelque chose de sympathique pour
tous les gens qui qui font du vélo le
dimanche en région parisienne et j'en
fais partie de faire du vélo est
heureuse et bien séjour sympathique et
elle a une histoire cette vallée donc
c'était aussi une façon de mettre un
coup de projecteur sur sur cette vallée
une étape qui devrait se disputer au
sprint dans les derniers mètres entre
les 22 équipes inscrites
la logique voudrait en effet cocoben
mars prochain médiateur il n'y est un
devoir un sprint
c'est l'une des quatre étapes de
paris-nice dévolue aux sprinteurs dont
la logique voudrait en effet que se sont
inscrits heures avec un très gros
plateau de sprinteurs cette année les
meilleurs du monde fit and fun
christophe est norvégien et les français
des mary boisnier le 6 mars les
cyclistes du paris-nice passeront
également par rochefort en yvelines une
commune de 900 habitants avant de
quitter le département au niveau de
saint-arnoult